le claquement des sabots sur la chaussée
un sont devenues habituelles pour ses
habitants
au passage de la police montée pourtant
c'est toujours le même émerveillement ma
c'est quand même nom surtout qu'ils sont
de très grande taille qu elle après à
côté on se sent vraiment petit
mais voir si c'est assez étonnant
ça fait bizarre de voir la police avec
les chevaux pourquoi ça fait bizarre
parce que j'en ai jamais fait je pensais
pas que ça pour que c'était vraiment
réel dans la riche
juchée sur ses talonnettes au mas ces
deux élèves de l'école de guerre d'un
cheval de soissons viennent renforcer
les effectifs de la police municipale
voitures mal stationnées donc fiat panda
violette il matricule et on va prévenir
la police municipale qui va surveiller
ces véhicules pour pas que ça se
reproduise et on fait vraiment beaucoup
de surveillance et sécurité donc ça va
être prévenir prévenir la population que
une interdiction c'est l'interdiction
chaque été depuis maintenant deux ans
les habitants de la commune peuvent
compter sur cette présence rassurante
les gens sont attirés par les chevaux
donc déjà nous ça nous permet d'avoir
une communication plus approfondie avec
les personnes et puis bon déjà c'est
vrai que des chevaux c'est sympathique
donc les gens il ya des sourires et où
d'après ça nous permet de discuter avec
eux d'avoir des informations qui doit
voir un retour positif
la brigade équestre de briare assurera
la sécurité et la sérénité de la commune
jusqu'à la fin de l'été